si vede si perfetto ragazzi devo
appoggiarla qua per forza visto che
bella tutti ragazzi venite questo nuovo
video sono fa dj ed oggi siamo in un
nuovo blog vero stavolta un blog vero
cioè non faccio il cazzone un po meno
del solito magari in teoria oggi non
sarebbe dovuto uscire blog perché sono
in texas e quindi non posso montarlo
però ho deciso di fare questo questo
specie di blog in live
insomma faccio pochi tagli poca roba
perché vi spiego che cosa cazzo sto
facendo qui in texas perché non l'ho
spiegato proprio bene faccio vedere
aspetta che ci sta signore e signori il
texas
c'è un parcheggio del texas prudenza ma
i miei ragazzi io sono praticamente qui
perché sa uscendo sta per uscire cioè
uscirà più avanti il videogioco di
valentino rossi che si chiama valentino
rossi the game
quindi niente mi hanno invitato come
ospite ho fatto anche c'è un sacco di
roba tipo commentato in diretta con
guido meda guido meda per chi non lo
conoscesse il commentatore della motogp
quello che fa
yo yo yo yo lo sapevo che dovevo dire
sta cagata ma io ci provo a imitarlo poi
non viene bene però paziente niente
ragazzi quindi sono giorni che va dal
circuito è veramente figo cioè io mi
tengo un poco di motogp mettendo
veramente poco però pian piano mi ci sto
appassionando perché veramente un mondo
figo mi piace veramente tantissimo turn
all 11 di aprile
tranquilli che usciranno gameplay tra
quell'unico video della nave era questo
lo sto facendo qui e lo monterò qui in
texas
sono pazzo maniaco sono le sei e mezzo
qua piume c'è il sole in italia ci sono
tipo e l'una di notte perché c'è il fuso
orario sto preparando il video speciale
quello riuscirà a sabato prossimo quindi
lo speciale per il texas che sto facendo
un sacco di video epici e non mi posso
far vedere tantissimo perché le clip
quelle belle le metterò poi nello
speciale texas niente ragazzi adesso vi
faccio vedere tra l'altro che l'altro
giorno sono uscito e ho comprato un
sacco di dove solo la prendo ho fatto
ragazzi nello shopping assurdo ho
comprato queste che sono fans che sono
strafiga come l'ho vista l'ho dovute
prende poi quale ero venuto
un cazzo ho preso delle magliette fans
sempre davanti s'avanza oggi tutto
pubblicità avanza la cazzo di cane e
adesso arriva il bello
tenetevi pronti sono ragazzi entrato in
un negozio che vendeva cose che non
potete capire iniziamo con questa c'è
ragazzi ho trovato la maglietta di file
night at freddi quanto può essere il
figlio stava glie l'ho trovata ed c'era
in un negozietto della minkia è
bellissima adesso in avanti ragazzi in
discoteca fare il tamarro con la foto la
maglietta dei fighters freddi e non
finisce qui i ragazzi perché ho comprato
anche la tassa il file knight e frey e
bellissima scritto freddy feedback pizza
che sarebbe la la pizzeria dove si
svolge tutto fi ne del predil come
ultimo gadget sempre dipendente 3d
svendevano anche questo credo sia per
tenere il caffè che io non bevo il caffè
però chi cazzo se ne frega dei ragazzi
completo altri co altre cose che ho
comprato un miliardo di cose in quel
negozio vendevano questo cioè
praticamente è un pacchetto di chewing
gum
solo che quando tiri la linguetta ti dà
la scossa e sta cosa qua è na figata
siete pronti a vedere l'epicità fatta
pupazzo la nona seriamente quanto può
essere figo come ultimo ragazzi tecnico
latte perché questo è il pezzo forte c'è
un gesù patrono ancora aperto possiamo
aprire dovrebbe essere ragazzi una
action figure di gesù sul seggio
elettorale dovrebbe essere una figata
cerchio è per l'iss evade scatolata
adesso non l'avevo ancora vista c'è
scritto ragazzi jesus for president
vabbè io adesso capite perché ho dovuto
prendere queste ne io ne ho bisogno come
ragazzi per adesso non ho preso
nient'altro grazie a dio perché sono
passati solo due giorni verrà rimesso
ridotto siccome non vi ho fatto vedere
una mazza nella stanza dell'hotel des
mezz'ora che parlo vi faccio vedere un
attimo come è strutturata qua e la mia
scrivania tutta bella in ordine come al
solito a e tre ragazzi mi sono immediate
di dirvi che siamo in milton che sarebbe
la catena degli hotel quella di paris
hilton niente io come premio gli ho
pagato nel cesso a paris hilton ne ho
pagato nel cesso qua fa caldo come se
fosse state in italia ci fa veramente un
caldo devastante giri in maglietta c'e
veramente come se fosse stata piena e la
cosa divertente che io le cose che ho
portato per vestirmi è tutta roba lunga
niente ragazzi questa è stata la crisi
ha attaccato perché io lascio sempre la
roba minchia e mi si attacca
ai piedi ragazzi che potete un po tutto
in teoria quindi andiamo a fare qualche
scherzo a qualcuno già che ci sia
vediamo i testare sto schifo se
effettivamente funziona questa ragazza e
l'ha vista dell'hotel interno c'è
l'hotel all'interno è così
luci
ciao brutta la vita è mio dio come ti
stai veramente spaccando il culo ho
pensato a una cosa e lo devo dire in
camera oddio aspetta che il primo
cavalesto l'inter merda tatuato sotto il
piede si se valentino domenica vince
visto che queste come dicevano oggi alla
gara di marker se vinceva le citato
balle sull'altro più markets merda sulla
a lunedì mattina documentato ci
svegliamo con la camera ha detto e se
vale vince markets merda sotto l'altro
piede wash anch'io
no non è vero perché non voglio che il
market sul mio corpo di unione dammi un
attimo volta ti abbassati felice si
veste come un [ __ ] vieni qui che va
in giro con l'etichetta ci hanno messo
prima per farla vedere l'etichetta
davvero non l'hanno detto lei ora io
prima non glie ne avete dette ok amici
siete in realtà non avevo ancora visto
la la piscina a per carina ma poi la più
che altro sono le sette di sera e vuole
come ha detto il sole lo so mica
incredibile ma questa è l'america
d'america
eh si lo so
house lo sai che uno scherzo però lo di
fare farlo per lotta che l'abbiamo preso
insieme quindi lui lo sa che è uno
scherzo però devi farlo per l'audience
dai che mi scrivo chewing gum [ __ ]
sotto il piede fa male stavolta te lo
giuro ho provato io prima dai ragazzi di
tagli e ho provato io prima e non
fossero hanno detto che non fa male ho
provato io prima zio giuro non è vero
che plate che desse un fifone arrivi
gesti parti di nova l'ho fatto io zio ma
veramente io l'ho fatto credi che
[ __ ] dai grazie per la città molto
gentile dai non fa male te lo giuro kira
non hai fatto niente che mi pizza
senonché leader della scala pazza
niente ragazzi voglio dire che posso
concludere quel video anche perché avrò
un anno e mezzo di video da montare e
niente i saluti questi sono gli uccelli
che salutano e niente ragazzi io e la
mia etichetta vi salutiamo visto che il
betis che l'hub di etichette attaccate
mais
se vi dove piaciuto la sento lasciato
come so io mi piace lo sta dicendo anche
l'uccello che è una frase brutta angela
pagina di facebook e come mi vedo tra
tale iscrizione video è manca il
telecomando però uso l'etichetta bei
ragazzi